countries in the world
unfortunately the pandemic still forces
us to have very limited people on site
and for those here being in the room
please make sure to always wear your
mask and keep the social distances it
would be highly appreciated
for those being at home following us
online welcome as well
please if you would like to ask uh
questions to us uh you have to register
yourself and login into the be too much
platform and also through mentimeter you
can ask questions during the whole day
and a team will follow up on your
questions and convey them to us
without further ado i want to introduce
our
first distinguished speaker who will
deliver to us a special address to all
of us
it's a big honor and privilege to
welcome the european commission
president usla van der leyen thank you
very much for being here with us today
thank you
[Applause]
so thank you very much bad
ladies and gentlemen
let me welcome you all both here in
brussels and online to the european
hydrogen week
we gather today
in
indeed the aftermath of the climate
conference in glasgow
and we all know the world is still not
on track to keep global warming below
1.5 degrees celsius
so we have to speed up significantly
yet i think progress was achieved in
glasgow on a number of key files
for example from an understanding
that global emissions must be cut by 45
by 2030 globally
to the fact that by now 90
of the countries have committed
themselves to climate neutrality
and clean hydrogen
was among the hottest
topics on the agenda of glasgow without
any doubt
and there was a wealth of exciting new
initiatives that we saw the light that
saw the light in glasgow
on our side
we launched a new partnership with bill
gates breakthrough energy catalyst
and the european investment bank
catalyst will help scale up critical
clean technologies
with a very specific focus on clean
hydrogen
it was just one of the many hydrogen
related
events in glasgow we saw
we saw for example new coalitions of
private companies that pledged to step
up their investment in clean hydrogen
we saw that big harbors in europe and in
the americas created new shipping
corridors for clean hydrogen between the
shores of the atlantic
dozens of countries and businesses
joined a dutch-led initiative to clean
up heavy-duty road transport including
through hydrogen
thus the evidence is growing
clean hydrogen will have a central place
in the climate neutral economy of the
future
and i'm very proud of europe's role as a
world's clean hydrogen trail blazer
at the beginning of this year
more than 200 new hydrogen projects have
been announced globally
55 of them
are in europe
so it's a leadership position that we
have built through years
for instance the european union started
before the rest of the world
to invest in a new generation of
electrolyzers
designed to be powered by renewable
energy
as a result
europe is now the world leader
in patents and publications of this
technology
some of the largest electrolyzers of
this new kind are already operating in
europe
for example there is one in linz in
austria
which produces green hydrogen to power
up a steel factory
we have financed it through our fuel
cell and hydrogen joint undertaking
and all these examples show that clean
hydrogen is already contributing to
decarbonizing our economy
and even better and that's important
it is beginning to be competitive
also from an economic point of view
because of the current rise in gas
prices we all see
green hydrogen today
can even be cheaper than grey hydrogen
so our target should be
to bring the cost below 1.8 euros per
kilo by 2030
and this goal is within reach
we have to scale up clean hydrogen
production
expand its applications
and create a virtuous cycle
when demand where demand and supply feed
each other and bring the prices down
that's the principle
this is without any doubt a global
endeavor but i want europe to be leading
the race
and this is the time to invest in
europe's leadership on hydrogen
for our own sake
and for the world's sake
now
how to
intend how do we intend to do that
first
strong public investment to innovate and
scale up
second
international cooperation to build a
global market for hydrogen
and third
our partnership with the private sector
and
researchers
on my first point
if we are to meet our climate goals
we need to accelerate an european
hydrogen economy
and this is why we have set the
ambitious target
to increase europe's annual production
of green hydrogen
to 10 million tons already by 2030.
this is a big step forward
we're now supporting this goal by
investing in projects
that are focused precisely on
accelerating the hydrogen uptake
just weeks ago for example we announced
seven new projects
with over one billion euros to be
financed by our innovation fund
and four of them
are hydrogen related
from green steel in sweden
to carbon capture in france
we also asked
our member states to put a spotlight on
hydrogen when drafting their national
recovery plans you know next generation
eu
if we look at the numbers more than 30
billion euros across our union will go
to clean energy investment of course
including including as a big pillar
clean hydrogen
hydrogen valleys we spoke about it are
perfect example of the hydrogen economy
we want to build
so take for example
the groningen area
and thank you bart for the video in the
northern netherlands
the region has large quantities of
renewable energy from its offshore wind
turbines turbines
two electrolyzers will use this
renewable energy to produce
green hydrogen
this hydrogen then will power up
industries it will fuel public transport
it will heat up homes
and be stored underground
by the end of 2025
the northern netherlands will host a
complete green hydrogen value chain
and this hydrogen valley will create
more than 20 000 jobs in the region
it is a project we are proud to support
and we're expanding the same model to
other areas there are many areas that
want to follow
from the islands of majorca
to the border region between italy
slovenia and
croatia and this is how we can
accelerate the hydrogen economy on a
local scale
on our way towards a hydrogen european
hydrogen economy as a whole
my second topic
i want europe to be a frontrunner
a frontrunner while building a global
market for hydrogen
last spring the european commission was
part of a coalition of countries
pledging to create 100 hydrogen valleys
around the world
of course we want the majority in europe
so clean hydrogen is becoming part of
the conversation with all our global
partners
of course including our african partners
africa has the greatest untapped
potential for renewable energy
production
and turning clean hydrogen
into clean energy into clean hydrogen
could be a solution
to store that energy
both to sell it abroad and to power
africa's rising industry
and it is with this in mind that i've
proposed to invest in africa's hydrogen
sector and thus creating a new clean
hydrogen market between the two shores
of the mediterranean
it could blink bring clean energy to
europe
and sustainable development to the
african country continent
our entire hydrogen agenda is about
cooperation
both at the international level
and inside europe with the business
world
and this is why we have launched the
european clean hydrogen alliance
this alliance has now more than 1 500
members
and it will be present of course during
this hydrogen week
a pipeline of viable investment projects
in clean hydrogen
for the first time
we will have a clear picture of all
hydrogen related initiatives in europe
linking ideas with potential investors
this morning
we're launching the new clean hydrogen
partnership
bringing together the european
commission
the hydrogen industry
researchers
and innovators
as well as policy makers from the member
states
this new partnership builds on years of
cooperation
promoted by the fuel cell and hydrogen
joint undertaking
and many things for that
and it brings that model to the next
level it's a new big step forward to
bring innovative technologies
from the laboratory
to the factory
and ultimately to european businesses
and consumers
the climate conference in glasgow was a
stark reminder
that the world still has a long way to
go towards climate neutrality
but today
clean technologies are rapidly becoming
reality
the first hydrogen planes could fly in
europe skies already the next in the
next decade
and thanks to next generation eu our
investment plan european cities such as
zagreb
will soon have hydrogen buses
or hydrogen fuel taxes in copenhagen
clean hydrogen is the energy of the next
generation
so let us speed up the transition
together
to reach climate neutrality by 2050 it's
a big goal
and to propel our economy already today
thank you very much for your attention
and welcome to the european hydrogen
week thank you
thank you thank you so much madam
president for your inspiring words and
for making the time for us to be here
for for us to be here today
also i will remember you said that
europe's role is to be the world's clean
hydrogen trailblazer and i cannot agree
more with you on that
but i'm president now it's time to
unveil our next partnership logo but
before that i would like also to call on
stage the different partners that we
have in our partnership firstly the
director general mr pacquiao
from the directorate research and
innovation please have a
you
then mr scott
uh from the chair of the joint
undertaking please uh can you stand here
thank you very much
then mrs van de vlis is the vice chair
of the joint undertaking and the
director of the clean planet in dgrtd
and then finally also mr anthony
the president of hydrogen europe
research
thank you very much
now here here's jean vicki
and
so madam president uh the word is back
to you
and after that please yes we will take
the picture
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
with a picture
uh